-We have exactly six shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It is time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Twelve Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Six days left ♪
-That's right, every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a whopper of a Christmas sweater
from the Countdown to Christmas
Cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since there are six shows left,
let's open door number six.
-Ready?
-I'm ready for this.
-I'm always ready.
-I'm ready.
-I appreciate this.
-Good. Ready?
[ Drum roll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I like this one. I like this.
Flowy.
Flowy, subtle.
I like this a lot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone,
look at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drum roll,
please?
[ Drum roll ]
2-8-2!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! Come on, bud.
♪♪
Yes, yes, yes!
Nice to see you, bud.
How are you?
Nice to see you, pal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-Ken Kavanaugh
from Austin, Texas.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Austin, Texas. We love it.
It does get a little chilly out
there in Texas
every now and then.
-Yes, it does.
-Yeah.
Do you have anything like this
that you could --
[ Light laughter ]
-No, I do not.
-No, you don't.
Would you like to try it on
right now for everyone?
Speaking about keeping it weird,
we've got to keep it weird,
Austin.
♪♪
Hang on. Here you go.
-Yeah!
[ Cheering ]
-Oh, yeah.
That's perfect.
Oh! Oh, this is perfect.
Are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is --
that's what you wear out.
This is fantastic.
One more time,
give him a round of applause.
Stick around.
We'll be right back.
Congratulations. Happy Holidays.